the great Jedi are a group of force
users who chose to distance themselves
from the Jedi Order
due to their conflicting beliefs in how
the force should be used in order for us
to understand why they chose to do this
so we first have to understand the force
and those who harness its power in the
Star Wars universe when we think of the
force we think of the Jedi and the Sith
the light and the dark side there are
two distinct sites who have conflicting
views on how the force should be used
the Jedi Order is structured much like a
religion with clear beliefs and rules on
how the force should be used that are
strictly adhered to they focus on
self-discipline selflessness and inner
peace as their path to the force and
they consider themselves to be the
guardians of peace within a galaxy on
the other side of course you have the
Sith a common misconception of the Sith
that the movies do not help to dispel is
that the syph are inherently evil
there is no denying that the Sith crave
power but whether the Jedi consider
emotions to be a path down the dark side
this if embraced their emotion these
emotions can be anger and hatred but
they can also be joy or love one of the
main reasons the Sith are depicted as
becoming evil is because they are
blinded or corrupted by their passion
and emotions the grey Jedi as their name
may suggest do not see the force in the
black and white terms of the Jedi and
the Sith do the gray Jedi see the force
as a spectrum of power with light and
dark philosophies on either side they
stand firmly in the middle believe in
that the only true way to master the
force is with a balance of light and
dark
a Jedi who disagreed with a council may
have been seen as a great Jedi and
despite this never being mentioned in
the Canon universe there are those who
consider qui-gon jinn to be a great Jedi
because of his many disagreements with
the Jedi Council we do see obi-wan
mention that if he's master would just
follow the code then he would already be
on the council alluding to the
possibility that Jin did not follow the
Jedi Code as closely as others
it was Jin's independence from the
council as well as his former master
Dooku joining a dark side that made them
wary of Jin possibly suspecting him of
being a great Jedi one could argue that
a line of great Jedi were indirectly
created through the teachings of qui-gon
jinn even after his death the series of
Padawans that followed in his footsteps
including obi-wan Kenobi Anakin and Luke
Skywalker all had severe disagreements
with the Jedi Code and more often seen
as maverick Jedi's potentially even gray
Jedi's if we take a look at ahsoka tano
from Star Wars rebels in the Clone Wars
she does fit into this line of potential
great Jedi left behind by qui-gon jinn
she was Padawan - anakin skywalker for a
short period and displayed behavior that
we've come to expect from a great Jedi
routinely disobeying the orders of the
council much like her master at the time
she was very aggressive and eager for
battle willing to use means that the
Jedi Council would not approve of to get
what she wanted in this case the term
great Jedi does not necessarily refer to
a Jedi who embraces a dark side but one
who doesn't fully comply with the
teachings of the Jedi Order such as not
being able to have a family or study and
learn the dark side of the force
[Music]
one of the most well known examples of a
great Jedi in the extended universe was
Joe Lee bindle Bindo was inducted into
the Jedi Order and trained in the ways
of the force at the Khorasan Jedi Temple
as a Padawan
Binda was considered to be reckless and
often ignored the word of the High
Council when he felt they were wrong he
eventually married a force sensitive
woman named Naima although marriage was
frowned upon by the Jedi Council Bindo
decided that he would train her himself
despite the council being against the
idea and the fact that he was still a
Padawan in this case the Jedi counsels
advice would appear to be correct as
bindas wife returned to the dark side
during the wall of Exar Kun she
attempted to turn Bindo but he rejected
her proposal which led to a lightsaber
duel between the two despite Binda being
victorious he could not kill his wife
and he let her go his wife would go on
to kill many Jedi before she was
eventually struck down in battle after
these events the Jedi Council did not
punish bin though they had hoped he'd
learned his lesson even offering to make
him a Jedi Knight at this point in time
Bindo had lost all faith in the council
and declined their offer going into
exile and living as a hermit on Kashyyyk
where he would fight alongside the
Wookiees and help them protect their
land against poachers Binda would
eventually come across one of the most
notorious Jedi in the extended universe
reven he chose to accompany Riven and
aid him in his victory of a Darth Malak
Bindo was heralded for his actions but
it wasn't long after he faded from the
public eye and disappeared forever
the great order believed in a balance of
all things not just the force alone
unlike the Jedi and Sith they chose to
watch over the Galactic Affairs without
intervening unless they deemed it truly
necessary they believed the force did
have two sides but neither was
inherently good or evil it was the
intention of the user that would
determine if the action was good or bad
the great Jedi were capable of using
dark side powers without falling victim
to its corruption a feat that the Jedi
believed to be impossible they even
taught that the great Jedi were unaware
of their own corruption the definition
of a great Jedi may confuse some as over
the years it has changed it could refer
to a Jedi who chooses not to associate
themselves with the Jedi Order or the
Sith in some cases it refers to someone
who disagrees with some of the teachings
of the Jedi Order and in others it
refers to those who have left the order
completely the Star Wars movie universe
has always been black or white with a
clear struggle between good and evil but
could we be seen in a shade of grey in
the last Jedi what about you guys
do you like the grey today do you even
think they should exist in a universe I
look forward to hearing from you in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained